as the corona virus pandemic rages on we
want to take a moment to tell you about
some of the remarkable people we've lost
some were known to the world others only
to their loved ones but each and every
one will never be forgotten here are
just some of the many lives to remember
with his distinctive beard Andrew Jack
stood out even in small roles and maybe
the planet in a pair of Star Wars movies
but in the film world he was famous as a
dialect coach he worked on some 80
pictures and helped create the
middle-earth accents in the Lord of the
Rings series it's like in the great
stories mr. Frodo the ones that really
matter
Andrew Jack was 76 chef's Floyd Cardos
won the third season of Bravo's Top Chef
Masters but growing up in India Cardos
dreamed of being a biochemist he said on
CBS this morning Saturday in 2017 and
then I started cooking and realized that
I was really good at it and I was like
wow I'm really good at this maybe I
should stand this his New York
restaurant table opened in 1998 would
reinvent Indian cuisine Floyd Cardos was
59
Dominican jenni Polanco was a pioneering
fashion designer whose work was
showcased in Paris New York and Miami
she described her style as a dialogue
between classic avant-garde and the
Caribbean jenny Polanco was 62
Alan Merrill co-wrote the classic song I
love rock and roll
born Alan Sachs in the Bronx in the 70s
he formed a glam band the arrows in
London that's where Joan Jett saw him
perform I love rock and roll the song
she'd take to number one in 1982 Alan
Merrill was 69 Manu Dibango scored an
international smash in 1972 with Sol
Mikasa blending jazz funk and music from
his native Cameroon the jazz giant
nicknamed happy brood died in France
Manu Dibango was 86
bill Hamrick was a professor of
sociology at City College in New York
who gained notoriety walking almost
every block of the Big Apple
6040 eight miles his book the New York
nobody knows became a best-seller on CBS
Sunday morning in 2016 he summed up the
city it's the greatest outdoor museum in
the world bill helm Reich was 74 there's
no place in the world like Detroit it's
the most authentic city in America and
I'll challenge anybody on that Marlo
stottlemyre was a tireless cheerleader
for the Motor City a business consultant
who championed young black professionals
he called his Young Lions Marlo a friend
said was the type of man who could see
you before you saw yourself he leaves
his wife Valencia who we met in 9th
grade biology and their two kids
Marlo stottlemyre was 43
Sunday rudder was a hero to her six kids
in Everett Washington after her husband
died in 2012 Sunday went to college kept
a job and still ferried her children to
sporting events and on special trips
diagnosed with breast cancer last year
she battled through but couldn't beat
the coronavirus she was a light her
oldest daughter Alexis says Sunday
rudder was 42 Jazmin Dixon known for her
huge smile worked at the Red Cross in
st. Louis but wanted to open a baking
business in February when some family
members couldn't make her birthday party
she drove around delivering cake to them
last month Jazmin Dixon became the first
person in st. Louis to die of
coronavirus she was 31 so many
remarkable folks we've already lost to
this virus we will continue to pay
tribute to them here and on social media
Gail that's why Anthony you know you
hear the numbers and you hear the
statistics and behind every single
statistic is a person who was loved who
was giving love and receiving love it
just shows you once again this
coronavirus does not discriminate it is
an equal opportunity heartbreaker that
was tough but I'm so glad you did it
it's so important to put a human face on
what is happening to all of us yeah I
totally agree and of course I also think
of our colleague Maria Mercator and all
of this the mind reels at the idea of
all these different people born in
different years in different places
living different lives and they all
collide with this same terrible virus
and you put it you put it rightly no one
is immune it does not discriminate
Anthony